welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Ahsoka
episode 4 Fallen Jedi a title that
applies to sabine's surrender to her
emotions ahsoka's literal cliff dive but
really it's us who have plunged into the
world Between Worlds to reunite with the
Fallen Jedi Anakin Skywalker or so we
think this realm in which the force
connects all of time and space was
actually seen in Rebel season 4 episode
13 when Ezra Bridger pulled Ahsoka Tano
through time saving her from her season
2 duel with Darth Vader and I cannot
believe we are now seeing it in live
action we're in an earth-shattering
moment of Star Wars folks so let's take
this scene by scene for all the details
you missed I translated runes I analyze
sounds I literally spent eight hours
writing this through the night after an
eight hour shift of a normal work day
and I did it because I love this and I
love you and I'm so grateful that you
support what we are doing and by the way
if you have not seen Rebels I don't
judge you it's okay we made a four-part
Rebels recap series for this reason to
catch you up on everything you need to
know our season 4 breakdown is now
incredibly important so please check it
out okay we opened this episode with the
usual faces of Vader 3PO clone trooper
helmet HK assassin Droid morocc huyang a
stormtrooper Chopper and sabine's helmet
every week sabine's helmet has been
flashing the color red now we realize
perhaps signaling her giving in to save
the one that she loves they're still
stuck on the planet sea toss or that I
want to thank metal dog14150 in the
comments of last week's breakdown for
pointing out is rooted in the ancient
Greek where Sito was the goddess of sea
monsters leading to the Latin sea tus
which means whale and also the name of a
constellation so we're gonna be doing
more to chat with you folks in the
comments so keep those great insights
coming and one of the very first lines
Sabine says this episode where's Ahsoka
outside and that is where we'd leave
Ahsoka at the end of this episode
wondering where she is and only knowing
that she is outside of our realm of
existence in the path of danger now the
Trees of citas are red leaves
reminiscent actually the Crimson
outgrowth formed in the Clone 4's mortis
Arc win the celestial deity figure the
son attacked to separate Anakin and
sister from Obi-Wan and Ahsoka if that
sounds like gibberish to you again watch
our Rebel season 4 breakdown and recap
it there but basically the gods of
mortis are a trinity of deities the
Father the daughter and the son the son
represents the dark side of the force
the daughter represents the light side
and the Father the balance in between
and again Ahsoka and Obi-Wan encounter
them in this realm that's called mortis
and a lot of stuff goes down but
basically the daughter transfers her
life energy to Ahsoka and lives on in
the form of a bird called Mori the gods
of mortis return and Rebels as The
Gatekeepers of the world between worlds
on a mural that's discovered on the
outside of the Jedi Temple of lothal and
it was the daughter's open hand that
Ezra Bridger followed two loath wolves
who Moved In A Circle opening the portal
to this Cosmic realm so it's kind of
important to know these Gods now Ahsoka
is really standing outside to avoid a
difficult truth with Sabine if we can't
make the journey to find Ezra then no
one should we should talk about this
Ezra bridger's name has always carried
an important meaning as Ezra means help
or helper in Hebrew and Bridger is
establishes this Jedi as a connective
bridge in Seasons two and three of
rebels is seemed to the dark side of the
force but really in season 4 proved to
be a bridge from this realm to the world
Between Worlds and now in this show a
bridge to paridia and Ahsoka fears
perhaps a Pandora's box that is not
meant to be opened Ahsoka says better
that
and allowing thrawn's return as heir to
the Empire
to the Empire of course a shout out to
Timothy zahn's 1991 novel that
introduced thrawn as a character to Star
Wars thrawn was considered the heir to
the Empire in the old Star Wars
continuity before that was retcon and
was brought back into Canon during the
age of the empire in Rebels and now
reclaims that position as the Imperial
Grand Admiral that all former Rebels
fear now Disney plus has gotten really
creative with their closed captioning
for Ahsoka because after Ahsoka says
heir of the Empire we hear this music
and the closed captioning describes this
as thoughtful music playing thoughtful
as in Sabine has to kind of chew on this
but also thrawn is the most thoughtful
thinker in Star Wars Ahsoka is not
looking forward to being outmaneuvered
though is everything all right
be careful out here yeah something
definitely stirs and Ahsoka looks to the
left and as she turns her the cool
dangles in such a way to kind of look
like a gust of wind is sending a shiver
down her spine it's like something a
presence she has not felt since shinhati
and maroc approach Morgan and balen's
skull as they look out from the citas
ruins and listen closely here
yes you can definitely hear pergol in
the sky above Morgan and balen watch
with some trepidation though because
remember those hyperspace whales did not
exactly help their side in that chase
last episode while this episode ends
with the eye of Sion blasting off on his
path of pritia I am guessing that Hera
Jason Chopper Ahsoka and for the love of
God better be Zeb and Rex too whatever's
left of the rebels crew it's gone to
follow this yellow brick road the
natural way and ride some pergol to
paridia Balin tells Morgan best get
underway soon is that a note of fear in
your voice experience so we later
learned this episode that Balin totally
knows that Anakin Skywalker became Darth
Vader and that Vader's former Apprentice
is not worth sticking around a face
Sabine now wears her Mandalorian armor
with the rebel Insignia on one Paul
drain and on the other a per gold so
this was the new color design that she
took on in the rebels final episode
epilogue she also wears these
Mandalorian van braces which look
customized from the ones Ben Rao gave
her in the trials of the darksaber
episode and she checks her blasters each
of them a westar35 five which are The
Blasters she uses in Rebels who Yang
surveils the tree line and we see the
droid's eyes narrow into these squinty
eyes like kind of a Clint Eastwood
checking out the Horizon and I love it
because it honestly shouldn't make a
difference for a droid's photoreceptors
it actually would make things worse but
it just characterizes him as kind of
human-like so I love it an HK Droid
attacks and huyang holds his own
surprisingly well for an architect Droid
designed to teach Jedi younglings about
lightsabers but who Yang uses his upper
shoulder arms to defend himself we
actually saw him grieve a scene with
these while training with Sabine in
episode 3 but hu Yang uses one of his
upper arms to break the motivator to
turn the power off and alert ahsoka's
being in a busted motivator sound
familiar that's how the Droid R5 got
Luke to take the Droid with a message
from Leia instead in a new hope it's
hard to you in another bad motivator
look busted motivators gotta love them
now when they're outside in the
firefight when Sabine is shot into a
defensive standstill Ahsoka shifts gears
and pulls this insane combination she no
look stabs the guy through the face of
her shoulder then she Force lifts
another guy into the line of fire of a
shooter killing that guy and it tosses
his corpse aside to let Sabine use your
van brace to lasso the last one right
into Ahsoka saber this is definitely
some dark side moves here and shows that
Ahsoka also is letting her attachments
to Sabine bring out some darkness in her
so we wipe to home one in the new
Republic Fleet as Harrison Doula and her
son Jason joined Chopper on the way to
the ghost and Jason remember is the son
of another Fallen Jedi Kane and Jairus
and he actually wears the same green
pauldron that Kanan wore throughout the
rebels series and it has kanan's symbol
and this symbol was seen on the head of
the loathwalk named Doom d-u-m-e sharing
his name with kanan's birth name of
Caleb Doom one unresolved mystery about
Kanan from Rebels is the question of
whether he might have been brought to
lothal as a youngling by Yoda kiarimundi
and Mace Windu foretold by the markings
depicting those figures on a wall in
that cave that the loath wolves LED them
to in Rebels season 4 episode 7 Kindred
if that's true that would give Kanan a
similar Miss connection to the planet of
lothal its Jedi Temple and the loath
wolves that Ezra had making them a kind
of kin drift through the force and how
Jason as the son of Doom who also gets
bad feelings akin to force sensitivity
and wants to be a Jedi also would share
in that kindred spirit whatever it is
Jason asks mom how come I have to do it
on holding you though
yeah it kind of sounds like Chopper says
boss
by five x-wings and I love how their
Shadow crosses over the top of that cr90
Corvette at the bottom of the screen
such amazing attention to detail there
in this Fleet if you look in the
background you can also see an ef-76
nebulon B escort frigate which first
appeared in Empire Strikes Back I love
seeing all these ships from the original
trilogy X-Wing Captain Carson tiva
played by Paul sung Hyun Li return to
the Mandalorian on your signal Phoenix
leader ah Phoenix leader he's recalling
Hera's role as commander of the Phoenix
Squadron during Rebels which could be a
sore subject because Hera and rebel
season 4 LED an attack Squadron of the
green painted x-wings as a phoenix
Squadron leader that led to a nasty
defeat by thrawn and her crash landing
on a lothal that resulted in Kanan dying
to rescue her but hey before that I
guess a lot of good memories in the
Phoenix Squadron we meet some other
Pilots including Lieutenant basey who's
played by Michael C Alexander with a
green and yellow helmet a rhodian
lieutenant moat played by Don dininger a
long time special effects crew and
costumer on many major titles Lieutenant
jensu played by ciao namova who's a
stunt performer and lieutenant Lander
played by Brendan Wayne who along with
Latif Crowder does all the physical work
for din jarn and the Mandalorian now
brynden is actually the grandson of John
Wayne and while we're at it Diana Lee
and of Santo is the goddaughter of Bruce
Lee don't call these nepo babies they
are stunt actors and no one in Hollywood
busts their asses for their craft more
than they do and I love how Herod does
the good Mama move that every good pilot
who rides Smugglers Run on Galaxy's Edge
does lets the co-pilot punch it into
hyperspace now we do this George Lucas
clock wipe and it's centered perfectly
on the center of the eye of Scion and if
that's not a clue that this hyperspace
jumper is also a kind of Time Machine
turning back the clock I don't know what
is now unlike in episode 2 when Baylen
looked up at those clouds and saw Pergo
here we do not see Pergo but we still
hear them
assist these users of Witchcraft Balin
warns but the jump we're attempting if
your calculations are off by even a
little
we will be lost to the depths of the
Void yeah balen seems to be referring to
a void between galaxies which sounds
like a kind of buffer zone that you
can't even jump into hyperspace from
Morgan tells Balin
now it might just be me but it kind of
sounds like there is an echo on her
voice similar to that of mother Towson
the ninth sister when she spoke in Clone
Wars I believe you have a question for
me have faith now balen responds to this
faith
I lost that a long time ago still
wondering about balance origin as a Jedi
and what other than the purge would have
caused his falling out now there's more
interesting clothes caption descriptions
when Morgan activates the sphere
ominous Whispering so the additional
voices at Sam whitwor Helen Sadler
Matthew hood and all the others are
contributing I think might be these
voices of the night sisters and the
Knight Brothers calling out to Morgan
from the path to paridia and perhaps the
world Between Worlds because these sound
like the night sisters from Clone Wars
Balin just takes all this in
witchcraft it's interesting that balance
because back in episode one he told Shin
not to Discount everything Morgan does
as witchcraft what threat is she
spending no it's not wagecraft but here
using night's sister's sorcery to
illuminate the path to britia to him is
Witchcraft and he senses that something
is unnatural about this now I pointed
out before that this hollow Dome star
map points a golden path through a ring
marked with Pergo but I just counted now
that there are eight of them which when
aligned with that eye of Scion in the
background and its seven hyperdrives
eight is more than seven and it could
suggest that this pod of pergol is a
more natural and more effective way to
hyperspace travel this route on eye of
Scion Morgan's Droid uploads this map
information on the segmented disc that
looks like an old school real-life
constellation map the screen on the
right kind of looks like a digital sex
Stant a device used by astronomers to
measure distance for Celestial
navigation and the wedges of the star
map screen light up yellow throughout
the episode like pieces of a clock and
recalling the rebels navigation map of
the death stars that orbited the oven to
get within range of the Avon 4 base in a
new oh makes a really effective visual
clock throughout this episode but if you
count these in total there are nine
sections that they have to complete and
figure out as pieces of the path to
Pyridium the number nine could
correspond to the nine Realms of Norse
mythology since that is a recurring
Motif on this series with skull and hati
being named after the Wolves of Norse
mythology and if you watch my video
where I translate all the different
runes on the path to pretty and the
closing credits the next stop on that
path to pritia is a planet called Odin
o-d-y-n Odin being the supreme god of
Norse mythology so Ahsoka is being run
into moroque and shin and like last time
they fought Sabine is the first to make
the move she rushes in now to her credit
Sabine is better with her blasters than
she's with her lightsaber so she's
initially on the offensive against Shin
she has pretty good aim shooting the
tree right where Shin's foot just was
but Shin does a pretty strong force push
that forces Sabine into Close Quarters
so that she has to draw Ezra's
lightsaber now meanwhile we do cut back
to the ruins and we briefly see some
runes in that alphabet that we started
to code in our closing credit star map
translation but again you should watch
but this one is veil of something I
thought it was veil of the force but it
is not that trust me even though the
veil of the forest does connect to what
we get to with the world Between Worlds
and thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video we here at new
rockstars love analyzing things and
we're pretty good at it if you want to
understand why a certain character acts
a certain way we can tell you that but
if you want to understand what's going
on with yourself you should talk to a
professional by using better help with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 30 000 licensed and experienced
therapists who can help you with a wide
range of issues whether you have a
clinical mental health issue like
depression or anxiety or if you're just
going through a rough patch therapy can
give you tools to approach your life in
a very different way if you click the
link in the description you'll see how
easy it is to sign up and get matched
with a therapist to get started just
answer a few questions about what you're
looking for from therapy and what your
preferences are better help will then
match you with a therapist from their
Network that's right for you and if you
don't really fit with that therapist
which is a common thing with therapy you
can easily switch to a therapist at no
additional charge without stressing
about insurance who is in your network
or anything like that if you're
struggling consider are online therapy
with better help click the link in the
description or visit betterhelp.com New
rockstars to help support this Channel
and get you 10 off your first month with
better help Ahsoka duels moroque and
she's far more patient she raises her
lightsaber over her head in a vulnerable
open position we think it's the same
pose that Anakin takes with Dooku in
Attack of the Clones but she does this
to bait maroc into spinning his
acquisitor lightsaber and Ahsoka way to
the right moment and slashes moroak real
fast it's a lot like the very quick duel
between Obi-Wan when he killed Maul in
the Twin Sons episode but then this
happens
[Applause]
I know I know the closed captioning is
exploding hiss and screams screams means
several voices are mixed into one so the
green Vapor means we are looking at
night sister sorcery like the green
flame that Morgan uses to activate the
sphere the green colored Knight sister
ghosts that inhabit the night's Easter
Temple the mall resided in on dathomir
and Rebels in three episode 11 visions
and voices it's pretty much confirmed
folks Baroque was not Ezra he was not
Starkiller he was not baristafi he
wasn't even the schistovanian Jedi like
I pitched even though I think that might
have been the most evidence based of
these wacky theories he was most likely
a knight brother a male member of the
night sister cult because dissipating in
a green vapor is exactly what happens to
Maul's brother the Knight brother Savage
press when he was killed by Darth
Sidious and Clone Wars season 5 episode
16. if he's not a night brother he might
have just been a corpse animated with
night sister magic the screaming sound
when he dies reminds us of when Grievous
slaughtered the night sister Clan and
Clone Wars season 4 episode 19.
foreign
connection could maroc have been Maul no
just stop why do people think this
Maul's death in the Twin Sons episode of
rebels was such a perfect end for the
character there is no way Dave filoni
would ruin that his own work by bringing
Maul back this way as like a knight
brother Spirit just to kill him off like
this also Ahsoka knows Maul she fought
it before she would have sensed his
presence broke was just Baroque let's
move on the one interesting thing about
this is that he is the first Inquisitor
we know of who was not a former Jedi
which is kind of weird balen tells
Ahsoka everyone in the order knew Anakin
Skywalker few would live to see what he
became surely that must leave a mark is
that why you walked away abandoned him
so Balin knows Anakin became Vader how
does he know this maybe he's very
perceptive through night sister magic or
maybe it's something he's learned from
Morgan ellsmith by way of thrawn because
thrawn deduced from various subtle
moments through subtext in books I also
just can't help but notice the probably
unintentional wordplay there few would
see what he became surely that must
leave a mark and you know what Anakin
came would leave us with a mark now the
runes behind Ahsoka In This Moment
translate to orbit of occlusion which is
a nod to the outer rim occlusion Zone
referenced in the high Republic Comics
so they ignite their lightsabers
[Music]
this is fascinating to me because
ahsoka's saber pitch is higher in tone
and I'm pretty sure these two harmonize
you have villains here and uh so cause
here which is a fifth above it here and
here so despite their opposition their
lightsabers produce this Pleasant
Harmony a Fifth Harmony you might say
you hear it especially in the shot where
Ahsoka sidesteps and Balin appears in
the foreground
and after their initial Clash Balin
takes the same batter up ready Stan says
Qui-Gon Jinn who's also a complex figure
in his relationship with the Jedi Order
now there is a moment when Ahsoka locks
Sabers with Balin but Balin doubles down
and shoves her blade back just with
brute strength and from here he has the
upper hand like Ahsoka whiffs pulling a
real Sabine there and then Balin does
this little midair twist looks awesome
and from here on you see ahsoka's
tactics changing she goes from fighting
balen to just dodging his throne
Boulders and reaching past him for that
map spear meanwhile Sabine tries to
force push on Shin but really sabine's
outstretched hand was just a ploy to put
Shin in the crosshairs of her vambrace
missile of Mandalorian trick that Kane
and Jerry scolded her for during trials
of the dark saber Balon really pisses
off Ahsoka by saying your legacy
death and destruction and now Ahsoka
gives into some dark side Rage with
chunky kicks she grabs a spear and the
night sister sorcery Burns her hand now
later we see her hand and it does kind
of look like that map might have been
burned onto her Palm like the headpiece
of the staff of raw and Raiders of the
Lost Ark you know lucasfilm loves to
just reference itself when Ahsoka sees
Shin without Sabine she assumes to be in
its dead and she Force Strokes Shin
slamming her against a rock yeah we're
seeing raw Dark Side energy from Ahsoka
not a good look and it might be her
starting to dip into this that really
sucked her into the world Between Worlds
and what is waiting for her there Balin
drives Ahsoka toward the edge and
overhead you can see the runes on the
ground translate to 2100 it's literally
the number spelled out in letters so
maybe this is a distance in like parsecs
to paridia I don't know so Sabine
threatens to shoot and destroy the spear
but Balin switches things up and appeals
to her through a non-violent path
yeah it kind of seems like baleen is
responding to a horn in the musical
score like he's sensing a connection to
Sabine appealing to her emotions I know
you feel that Ezra Bridger is the only
family you have left your family died on
Mandalore because your master didn't
trust you whoa this is new information
we last Saw sabine's family including
Ursa ran Tristan Wren and Alger grin
Allah live and well in the first two
episodes of rebels fourth season but not
anymore rip House of Ren but moth
Gideon's night of a thousand tears is
Purge struck Mandalore with Fusion bombs
which now must have happened after the
battle of Endor between 4aby and 980y
sometime after Sabine joined Ahsoka in
that Rebels finale scene so now we know
the reason for sabine's anger toward
Ahsoka is that Sabine believes she could
have saved her family from that bombing
but Ahsoka refused to Let Her Go Balin
offers to being the chance to reunite
with Ezra if he joins her it's a similar
test that Ezra undergoes with Emperor
Palpatine in the rebels final episode
but whereas Ezra resisted that
Temptation Sabine gives in and it's a
big mistake that she feels right away
because the bean starts gasping from
Shin's Force choke Vengeance probably
for what Ahsoka did to Shin violence
begets violence but you know Sabine is
feeling that reward for joining the dark
side sometimes the wind gets sucked out
of you balen it destroys the sphere and
the eye of Scion rises from the citas
atmosphere and the Phoenix Squadron
engages lawcast spoils an attack
position yes the same order given by the
red leader during the Battle of Yavin
and A New Hope La gas spoils an attack
position and just comes back again and
again in Star Wars but Morgan doesn't
engage she just orders to jump to
hyperdrive and we're worried because
even though the holder maneuver hasn't
technically been invented yet it is kind
of a hole to maneuver but just because
the ring is too big it just kind of
leaves this insane wake
holy this hyperspace wake causes at
least two of the X-Wing Pilots
lieutenant basey and Lieutenant moat to
collide it's kind of hard to tell but it
kind of looks like Lander might have
gone down too it kind of seems like
Carson tiva is okay the other one's
either jensu or Lander we will see but
Jason says huh
I I've got a bad feeling hey welcome to
Star Wars kid of course it's a nod to
the recurring I've got a bad feeling
about this line and pretty much all Star
Wars titles but in this instance Jason's
Force sensitivity is telling him that a
Pandora's Box was just opened and here
comes the good stuff we transitioned
from an overhead shot of the citas ruins
and the waves cross dissolving into
ripples of Stardust we don't even
realize initially that we've gone
somewhere new that's how smooth the
transition is and that's how smooth it
was for Ahsoka because she finds herself
on a glowing path in space with lines
streaking across the sky this can be
only one thing my friends it is the
world Between Worlds from Rebels season
4 episode 13. it's a cosmic realm in
which the force connects all points in
time and space now in animation the
pathways are glowing in white but here
they are blue and they Ripple like water
which connects them aesthetically to
citas and the pergol and the blue watery
tunnel look of hyperspace now when Ezra
Bridger goes into this realm and Rebels
he hears Echoes of lines from Star Wars
past present and future including the
sequel Trilogy it's crazy he sees Ahsoka
through a portal in time back to her
season 2 duel with Darth Vader he pulls
her away from Vader's killing blow in a
way he closes the loop as this justifies
how ahsoko is able to survive that now
Ezra mistakenly wants to try to use this
to prevent kanan's death but he learns
that he cannot change the past Palpatine
sees them through a portal and he tries
to snare Ezra with blue fire Ahsoka goes
back to malachor Ezra uses the mural of
the sun to destroy the temple Now Dave
filonia said that he doesn't see the
world Between Worlds as time travel he
didn't want to leave it open-ended but
rather he kind of sees it as a one-time
way for Jedi to see through time but you
know Ezra did kind of affect things so
my man that's the kind of time travel
and now it seems like napaloni has
reopened the box so will Ahsoka go back
in time and change things I don't know
about that this could just be how Ahsoka
looks into the past or looks into the
future if it is indeed true that thrawn
and Ezra are in a different time because
Morgan Ellsworth did say that thrawn was
calling to her Through Time Ahsoka in
this episode told Balon that she didn't
want to talk about her past and he said
he wanted to secure the future so a
battle between the future and the past
and for Ahsoka this is all about the
past and again this is not ahsoka's
first time in the world Between Worlds
when she first entered this realm her
bird Mori was already there waiting for
her it was the daughter specifically who
opened the portal for Ezra and the
daughter lives through Ahsoka now the
world Between Worlds isn't supposed to
be accessed through death or near death
in ahsoka's case but ahsoka's connection
to the daughter plus the Witchcraft that
was being used on that pedestal in the
overall Mystic nature of these citas
ruins and what Ahsoka goes through this
episode her flirting with dark side
power may have caused Ahsoka to dive
into her subconscious Now Dave filoni
has likened her with Gandalf and this
could be like when Gandalf the Gray dies
falling off the ledge fighting the
balrog and then he returns later
enlightened as Gandalf the White the
episode titled time to fly could have
been ahsoka's
so who would be ahsokas fire demon well
from the mortis Arc and Clone Wars the
god the son lived on through
master
I didn't expect to see you so soon
and again oh Sky guy wait what's wrong
with your face Hayden Christensen is
back I love it Snips was of course
Anakin's nickname for Ahsoka in the
early seasons of Clone Wars when they
often butt heads and I love how Anakin
appears over her left shoulder just as
he did In Rebel season 2 episode 18
shroud of darkness when Ahsoka sensed
visions of Anakin and Vader in the
lothal Jedi Temple for Guilt working
through her choice to abandon him in the
Jedi Order so
why did you leave where were you when I
needed you do you know
what I've
foreign
Christensen has been de-aged for this
but I think he was meant to look a
little Ghostly and just off because a
the animated version of Anakin was
really the Anakin that Ahsoka knew and B
I don't think this is Anakin like at
first glance we think this is Anakin
right before Revenge of the Sith when
Ahsoka said goodbye to him in Clone Wars
season seven the last time they saw each
other before he turned into Vader during
the events of Revenge of the Sith
essentially the essence of Anakin that
died when Vader took over sure sure I
get it I get it the Force ghost that
George Lucas weirdly put in in that 2005
DVD special edition of Return of the
Jedi and everyone was really mad but
look closely at his lightsaber it's hard
to tell but at first glance this looks
darker than Anakin's lightsaber almost
more like Vader's lightsaber which is
similar in structure but it has more
black pieces throughout the hilt it is
possible that the Chrome of Anakin's
Hill is just reflecting his dark robes
and reflecting the dark surroundings but
what's throwing me is the silver clip at
the center of it I don't know if that
part would be so brightly silver while
the rest of the hilt is that dark and
the Chrome of it not even catching any
of the blue light that Anakin's skin is
catching and to be clear the silver clip
is not how the saber attaches to his
belt the hilt hangs from the pommel like
most lightsabers do now Anakin does bear
the scar that he got from massage
Ventress during clone wars that he had
in Revenge of the Sith but there's just
enough here to think that he is sus also
he has this ghostly blue pallor that
recalls the blue fire used by the
emperor to see into this realm it's the
same Sith sorcery that he used to try to
corrupt Yoda's Mind through a connection
with Dooku when Yoda was on moravan in
Clone Wars season 6. now the world
Between Worlds and Rebels is not known
to have ghosts in it and mortis Obi-Wan
talks to Qui-Gon but Rebels World
Between Worlds it's just supposed to be
voices so I think since Mori the
representation of the daughter was
already there for Ahsoka and this realm
is totally linked with the mortise Gods
it is possible that this Anakin is not
Anakin but is the form of the Sun a
representation of the dark side as that
mortis Arc in Anakin's connection to the
sun was really a moment that
foreshadowed Anakin's Destiny as a a
fallen Jedi now this lightsaber may just
end up being Anakin's lightsaber but if
there's something suspicious about it
who knows it could be a disguised form
of the dagger of mortis and if Sam
Whitworth does have a live-action role
on this series I don't know having him
play the sun would be perfect casting as
it would justify why we've been hearing
his voice in the mix now I think episode
5 is going to allow Ahsoka and Anakin to
reconnect give us that visual again at
least at first but it may give way to a
duel if this ghost Anakin is revealed to
actually be the sun it gets the final
seconds of the episode hint that we are
in for a dark side take on Anakin listen
closely
[Music]
foreign
that is 100 the notes of The Imperial
March Darth Vader's theme what an
episode comment down below with your
theories on what this Ahsoka series
plans to do with the world Between
Worlds and with fake Anakin or Fennekin
or how about Anna's skin Anna skin maybe
we'll work on it support our Channel by
grabbing and Ahsoka inspired bulkrum
shirt available at nerd riot.shop be
sure to subscribe to the break room for
episodes of WikiLeaks our Ahsoka after
show subscribe to all three channels of
the new rockstars Network and hey thanks
to Noah Chen for helping write and
research this breakdown follow me at EA
boss follow me rockstars thanks for
watching see you next time bye
[Music]
thank you